[Music]
halloumi is a firm springy salty cheese
with his roots firmly in cyprus and
grease
the betalumi is made from sheep's milk
rich in vitamins and essential nutrients
is thought to promote longevity
halloumi keeps for many months if stored
unopened in the fridge and its high
melting point makes it brilliantly
adaptable perfect for grilling
barbecuing and frying
i'll be championing this texture lending
marvel for my yummy vegetarian lunch
dish of halloumi courgette and herb
cakes
as a chef i'm never sniffy about cooking
with vegetables because i know that with
a bit of care and attention they can be
turned into something absolutely
stunning for my ultimate vegetarian
lunch i've got a couple of fantastic
recipes
lightly fried my delicious halloumi and
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables
but first i'm preparing a simple slow
roast tomato and watercress
salad these cherry tomatoes are perfect
if you haven't got cherry tomatoes
vitamins are good or even just big
normal plump tomatoes lay the tomatoes
on the tray
and these go into the oven for about 90
minutes
if you turn the oven down really low you
can leave them in overnight to be honest
the longer you leave them the better
they taste
once you've seasoned them with salt
sprinkle over with some sugar
and the salt and sugar combine speeds up
the drying process because you want that
nice chewy texture and then you get
these little time flowers and just pick
off the buds garlic sliced
then just spread that on
now the tray looks quite full and
compact but 90 minutes in the oven
you'll see everything shrink down all
the skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes
place your tomatoes into an oven
preheated to 150 degrees c and cook long
and slow for an hour and a half
now halloumi cakes there's something
quite exciting about halloumi cheese
it's a very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
peel the carrots
[Music]
great not too finely you want that nice
texture
next courgette
the secret is it all grated the same
put that into a sieve
[Music]
a sprinkling of salt will draw out
liquid from the vegetables
then grate the halloumi
halloumi cheese doesn't look that tasty
but once you've got color on it in the
pan it's really
really delicious now
really important to squeeze out the
excess water from the veg
and we'll see all that water that needs
to come out of there if you didn't do
this it will make your little patties
non-friable because the whole thing
starts to separate
and then mix in with the cheese
spring onions chop up the whites and the
greens
now we're going to season that with some
delicious fresh mint and fresh coriander
whenever it's vegetarian i like to put a
combination of herbs in there tarragon
parsley mint coriander basil and
lemongrass
all delicious on their own but in tandem
their flavors play off each other
next
two eggs
in
give that
a little mix
add the eggs to the mixture and then
finally a couple of tablespoons of
breadcrumbs the breadcrumbs help dry out
any excess moisture
mix
all the ingredients together
before you start shaping these taste the
mixture
it's really important to identify the
seasoning now
if you wait until you've cooked them
it'll be too late to adjust the
seasoning
roll them to a large golf ball
shake them like a little mini burger
you could spice these up with some chili
in there if you haven't got fresh chili
chili flakes
and it's something that can be done up a
day in advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes
pan on
get that nice and hot whilst i'm waiting
for that i'll get the dressing ready
slice the red chili seeds and all on an
angle into shards
then chop fresh ginger
season with a sprinkle of sugar and salt
add some rice wine vinegar
add a couple of tablespoons of olive oil
to finish off some chopped coriander
[Music]
got that sweet sour spicy flavor with my
chili dressing done i can start frying
off my halloumi cakes in a hot oiled pan
we get a nice crisp edge
you can already start to smell that
sauteed halloumi with the
courgettes and carrots smells delicious
really important for a nice amount of
color on them
as my cakes sizzle away i can finish off
my roast tomato salad
one of my favorite leaves has to be
watercress it's cut off stalks
[Music]
shallot rings
watercress and shallot
go brilliantly well together
the shallot looks so dainty when you
open up these little ringlets
[Music]
don't forget to turn your cakes
now tomatoes whatever you don't use just
jar them and put them in the fridge
[Music]
just drop those slow cooked warm
tomatoes over the watercress the
sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious
a little drizzle of age of smoked
vinegar
gives that tartness to the watercress
watercress is naturally peppery so it
doesn't need any pepper just a little
touch of salt
and then a light
sprinkling of extra virgin olive oil
after five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready
so important to have taken out that
water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate
and then just get your dressing take a
spoon of it
and then tilt it to the side because i
want the garnish i don't want the juice
if that does not
turn you on to become a vegetarian for
the night i honestly don't know what
will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
herb cakes with a sumptuous roast tomato
and watercress salad all of the flavor
with none of the meat
murgues and fontina stuffed croissants
okay
big and bold i was living in france i
stayed there for three years
once twice a week i treated myself to
the most amazing
bold breakfast and it started off with
these beauties here murgays cheap but
incredibly tasty
start off with a nice hot pan
mug is in
it's a very spicy sausage doesn't need
any help doesn't need any chili
just a touch
of salt and pepper
you can smell
the spice
let's start to release all that
wonderful oil that flavor in there
add a couple of cloves i'll finely slice
garlic
spread the garlic across the pan it
instantly changes color takes on this
nice dark rich
golden color
now take a look at the heat out with the
parsley
the stalks of soft herbs like parsley
and coriander can be used to impart
flavor during cooking but the leaves
should always be added just before
serving to give maximum color and
fragrance
[Music]
and then finish that off with my capers
amazing all right
beautiful
now
take your quests on
they're literally 24 hours old so
they're crispy on the outside and just
slice off
the lid
this recipe is a great way to use up any
leftover croissants from the day before
i used to cringe when i saw the french
cooks throw away croissants i used to
cry thinking oh my god
any idea what you're throwing away in
terms of flavor
whatever you do do not wipe out that pan
dunk
your croissants mopping up all that
amazing flavor and caramelizing the
inside
for that beautiful and don't forget the
lids
and then get your thumbs
and go inside the croissant
all i want to do now is just create a
little pocket
and just manipulate the crescent now
this is where it gets exciting
mix up
the capers the garlic and sausages
look at the color
of that wonderful
delicious flavoured
oil now some cheese
but not just any cheese fontina cheese
is like the number one cheese for
grilling and because it's a very rich
cheese you shave it thinner than you
would a white truffle but it gives a
really nice saltiness and a light smoky
flavour
salt
place these big boys on the tray
literally 30 seconds
on the grill
here we go
nice
crisp
packs full of flavor
now top them
and that for me
it's almost like being back in paris
except this time
i don't have to share them with the
french
my ultimate big and bold breakfast
murgies and fontina stuffed croissants a
great way to start the day
spicy black beans with feta and avocado
[Music]
first in a pan heat olive oil add
chopped onion and fry until soft
then finely slice garlic
and chili
add cumin
cinnamon
and black beans then combine
cook together until deliciously soft
these small beans come dried or in tins
and they're a great cheap ingredient to
make dishes more substantial
to serve dollop the black bean mixture
on crunchy tortillas
topped with cubed ripe avocado chopped
fresh coriander and crumbled salty feta
cheese
spicy black beans with feta an avocado a
dish has filling frugal and tastes
fantastic
my next great veg recipe is
leaking greer rusty with fried eggs
[Music]
in a hot pan sweat shredded leeks along
with a knob of butter and seasoning
next
great par ball potatoes and grill a hard
swiss cheese with a great nutty flavor
then combine with the softened leeks
in a pan heat oil and a little butter
spoon in the potato leek and cheese mix
cook gently until golden and crisp
underneath
then slide onto a plate
flip over and return to the pan to
finish cooking
[Music]
finally for the perfect topping fry two
eggs
and place them on top of the rosty
top with fresh tarragon
[Music]
leaking grill rusty with fried eggs a
simple but substantial dish that makes
the most of hearty root veg
what could be more classically british
than the cheese that's been produced
here since the 12th century cheddar
originally made in the caves of the
cheddar gorge in the west country it's
still far and away the uk's cheese of
choice in britain cheddar outsells all
the other cheeses combined
good quality cheddar has an amber yellow
hue and it's firm but not greasy or hard
a dish becomes a classic because it's
delicious and somehow strikes a cord
with us it just works sometimes these
dishes can become tired but a clever
twist helps make them fresh again
you can't get more classic than a
centuries-old midday meal of bread
cheese and beer
reinvented and marketed by pubs as a
plan was lunch in the 60s i'm now giving
it my 21st century take
like plum ones with the most amazing but
super simple beer baked bread hearty and
full of flavor
for a really quick and easy bread dough
sieve a mix of wholemeal and
self-raising white flour with a good
pinch of salt
salt is really important to breath it's
the first thing i do once i've cracked
it and smelt you want to smell that salt
baked throughout
beer in
about 250 mils of beer
[Music]
the reason why this recipe works so well
is it the beer it's got that yeast so
naturally it's going to work beautifully
give that a really good mix
i'm looking for the mixture to be quite
wet if the dough becomes too firm then
it's gonna cook
dry in the center
just as it starts to fall through the
whisk that is perfect
beautiful
this mix will work really well as one
large loaf but i want to make my plum
ones a little bit more special
small tins give it that kind of intimacy
and i quite like having my own little
loaf
give the molds a really nice
lining with butter make sure
you butter the top
now
tablespoon of flour dust inside the mold
that will stop your mixture
sticking
tap out
any excess three-quarters fill your
little moulds we're gonna allow it to
sort of rise
just so it comes above the mold and
forms this really nice miniature loaf
onto the tray centimeter apart
into the oven 25 to 30 minutes at 180.
something quite nice about the smell of
home-baked bread in the kitchen
delicious
no plan was it's complete without
pickled onions
red onion is a lot sweeter less harsh
than a white onion the
early days of
plum and you've got those ghastly sharp
pickled onions that
make you almost cry when you're
crunching them i'm gonna lightly pickle
my
red onion
just push your fingers through so you
get these nice sort of onion rings
a little touch of salt and sprinkle the
sugar and then a couple of cloves in
there that gives it a really nice sort
of perfume and sort of makes the
pickling slightly more mellow
red wine vinegar now if you haven't got
red wine vinegar white wine vinegar it's
just as good but red matches the red
onion so it goes hand in glove a couple
of tablespoons of vinegar
just give that a really good
mix
to speed up the pickling process use a
weight to put pressure on the onions
as the weight presses down on the onions
the clove the salt the sugar the vinegar
worked their magic and it comes out with
a really nice light fragrant pickle
for my 21st century plants i'm creating
an all-in-one salad and bringing the
traditional elements together with a
punchy dressing
a tablespoon of english mustard
a tablespoon of honey
a touch of salt and pepper
and finish off with white wine vinegar
and olive oil
[Music]
now generally
it's sort of three parts oil to one part
vinegar that's the sort of general base
[Music]
you don't really think of a vinaigrette
with a plan ones but this is a really
nice sort of modern
approach to plan ones
for my plan one salad i'm using a
mixture of robust and crunchy romaine
lettuce
and punchy watercress
if i was making a watercress soup i'd
use the stalks but the stalks are a
little bit bitter so i just grab them
like that pinch them and then twist
[Music]
very peppery
very hot
but so juicy watercress in
your celery chop it nice and finely it's
the one thing that everybody leaves is
that stick of celery so
scatter it amongst the salad
a bit of oomph and color from some
sliced radishes and sweetness from a
thinly sliced apple
whilst you're busy throwing your plum
and salad together do not forget about
your beer bread
before it comes out i'm gonna glaze the
top with a little touch of milk that'll
put a really nice finish to the bread
back in for the last five minutes
now for the magic and the plain ones
generally you'll see it as a ham or
cheddar or stilton players it's hard to
dictate which one's the best
so for the ultimate plowman's i'm adding
all three
with your cheddar
peel some nice shards of that delicious
creamy cheddar just get them dancing on
top
the dressing
drizzle ran in circles
and then finally
our delicious lightly pickled onions
give them a good squeeze
and look just dot the onions around
bread
it's ready
it's got that nice
yeasty smell
warm
crusty and delicious
there you go
that is my classic modern version
of a traditional stunning ploughman's
wow
[Music]
my delicious all-in-one plan one salad
with individual beer bread loaves
updated for the 21st century
[Music]